foreign
I want to thank you for joining our talk
today on making container application
development simpler scalable and faster
I'm Drew broadstock and I'm responsible
for product management for kubernetes
and joining me today is Jason politis
who is responsible for product
management for all of serverless
in the past two years we've seen
customers of all sizes and backgrounds
Embrace containers as the modern unit of
compute so fundamentally why is this
occurring it's all about developers and
the fact containers help them make them
more productive and faster and
kubernetes and serverless are key to
embracing containers
but a lot of people ask well why Google
at our heart we're container first be it
with Cloud run or with gke we've made
sure the containers are fully supported
across all aspects of Google cloud and
heavily optimized for them as well
what this means for you is that you can
build a fast streamline Dev platform if
you look at building pushing and
deploying with Cloud builds or moving on
and auto redeploying your changes likely
many many many times all the way to
leveraging Cloud run and gke to be able
to scale your workloads globally at no
matter what issues and scale is needed
Jason
thanks Drew so containers are a great
way to drive productivity and
portability across environments and
we've been looking at ways to make
running containers in the cloud as
simple and as fast as possible
with Cloud run you can quickly and
easily run containers in the cloud
without having to manage any
infrastructure you can think of it as
clusterless containers you just deploy a
container and it runs there's no
provisioning step so you just focus on
your app
we support standard Docker and oci
container image formats so you can build
a container using your own CI system and
bring it to Cloud run but we also
integrate with Cloud build which will
build the container image for you either
from a Docker file or just directly from
source code using one of the open source
build packs we support the build pack
will automatically detect the language
you're using and build the container for
you
cloudron also works with Cloud deploy so
you can set up deployment pipelines with
approval steps to manage the requirement
of services into production
car run has two main resources services
and jobs services are request-based
containers used most often for things
like external or internal web
applications apis or microservices they
can use HTTP HTTP 2 grpc websockets and
can even be treated asynchronously with
events
one of the great features of services is
traffic splitting and this allows you to
gradually roll out changes to a service
or quickly roll them back if something
goes wrong
so you just set a percentage like five
percent and the new version of your
service will only receive five percent
of traffic whereas the previous version
is still receiving 95 and then you just
gradually increase that and if anything
goes wrong you just set it to zero
and of course Services Auto scale so
when there's no traffic on the service
it'll scale down to zero and then when
traffic arrives it will automatically
scale up to meet demand
the other resource is jobs jobs are
great for background data processing
workloads so you might have a batch
process you want to run nightly maybe
you're cleaning up some data or
generating some reports you can schedule
jobs to run at a given date and time uh
you can trigger them manually or you can
trigger them via an API call
and jobs have an inbuilt retry mechanism
which improves the reliability of task
completion
now I want to just quickly touch on some
of the common use cases for cloud run uh
the first and probably most common is a
scalable web application now Cloud run
is a regional product which means that
within a region we provide zonal
redundancy regions in Google Cloud are
made up of several zones or cells and by
default Cloud run is operate in multiple
cells automatically providing that first
layer of redundancy but you can also
deploy Cloud run as a global Service
with regional failover using a load
balancer an interesting side effect of
the scale to zero behavior of cloud run
here is that when a region is not
receiving any traffic Cloud run is
scaled to zero and it's effectively idle
making it very cost effective to go from
a regional to a global Service
the load balancer also provides features
like CDN or caching static resources and
it will automatically choose the closest
region to the end user
the next common use case is internal
apps or apis Cloud run is not only for
services exposed to the public internet
you can also operate private services
that cannot receive requests or send
data outside your VPC boundary this is
useful when your service needs to for
example access information from another
internal system within your VPC
the third example is what I alluded to
earlier with Cloud run jobs uh this
might be a simple data transformation
job that executes on a schedule extracts
data from cloud storage maybe it does
some day cleansing deduping or data
enrichment and then loads into bigquery
to drive analytics and Reporting and
just like with Services when a job is
not executing it's effectively idle and
so it's not built it's only billable
while it's executing
so I'm now going to hand it over to
bitsy who's going to show you a quick
demo of deploying container to Cloud run
thanks Jason I have a small business app
I want to deploy to Cloud run
let's get started I'll click create
service
I've already containerized my app and I
stored the image in artifact registry so
I can select the image here
I'll click on the latest version and
press select
for the purposes of this demo I'll make
my service publicly accessible
let's click create now
Club run is now creating my service
notice what I didn't do I didn't create
a cluster
I didn't configure a load balancer
Cloud run automatically created an https
URL for me let's click it and see if my
container runs
Ah that's right I need to finish my
application setup now
the first step is to connect my data
stores my app stores data in a redis
instance and files in a cloud storage
bucket
and I need to tell my app where they are
using environment variables let's push a
newer efficient with the right
environment variables I'll click edit
and deploy new revision
I'll scroll down to environment
variables
and enter the internal IP address of my
redis service
I've already set up a memory store
instance in the VPC before this demo
memory store is managed threat is on
Google Cloud
and I'm also adding the name of the
cloud storage bucket here
I'll also need to connect the cloud run
service to the VPC let's scroll back up
to connections and select the default
Network
that's it let's click deploy again
Cloud run is deploying the new revision
and routing all traffic to it
okay this is great as you can see Radice
is green and that means my app was able
to connect to my memory store instance
on the VPC
the bad news is that my app wasn't able
to connect with cloud storage my service
account doesn't have permissions to
access the bucket I will push another
revision of my service to fix that I'll
click edit and deploy new revision
and now I'll go to the security tab
before this demo I created the service
account for my service and granted it
the storage admin role on the bucket
now I need to configure my cloud run
service to use the service account
let's select the service account and
click deploy again
Cloud run is now deploying another
revision
and when it's ready I'm going to click
the link
and see if it works yay it works
let's wrap up I deployed my collaborate
service and connected it with a memory
store instance on the VPC and with a
cloud storage bucket with both data
stores connected I can start loading my
data and using my internal business app
I'm gonna add it back to Jason now
thanks Lucy
so Cloud9 is a great way to build and
deploy Cloud applications at scale
but if you're using kubernetes or you
want to build your own platform on top
of kubernetes then you'll want to use
gke
gke is kubernetes conformant so you can
easily move existing kubernetes
applications into gke and leverage the
rich ecosystem of third-party kubernetes
operates if you are building a platform
you can also use anthos to accelerate
this platform building process I'm going
to hand it back to Drew now to tell you
more about gke
thanks Jason so Google Remains the
largest contributor to kubernetes and
you can really see this within gke and
it's different to be compared to other
offerings within the market
fundamentally GK makes kubernetes easy
now a lot of people ask well what is the
actual difference one of the core things
that we've actually invested in is the
work around fifteen thousand uh node
scaling many people think hey it's just
a large marking number but that wasn't
the purpose we actually wanted to make
sure that no matter what workloads you
through at us that they'd scale easily
and reliably and that reliable scaling
is critical within key business points
secondly we've been investing a lot
within day two operations be it upgrades
release channels but a lot of the work
we're doing within the community uh and
with many customers around making
deprecations easy all that work on day
two means that it's cheaper and easier
to run kubernetes with gke so fast get
clusters going and even faster to be
able to get your workloads deployed one
of the cool things bringing this all
together is autopilot and we've got an
offer that we can encourage you to check
out and it's got a cool URL the goo dot
GLE slash GK Dash offer if you want to
see more autopilot in action
now autopilot for us was about bringing
together all the great features that GK
has and a lot of that auto scaling Auto
management into one fully managed by
Google offering this is SRE supported
it's also as Jason mentioned earlier
autopilot is kubernetes conformant that
means you've got the flexibility to move
other workloads into it or move from GK
into GQ autopilot because it's all one
offering we've heard a lot of great
feedback from all of you in the past
year on what else we needed to build in
autopilot so that you can use it at
Great scale with that we're actually
really happy to announce it a couple
weeks ago we made autopilot the default
version or mode of kubernetes because of
the changes that we've actually be able
to make within the platform
autopilot brings together a lot of the
lesson learned we have from running
millions of nodes and a great deal of
clusters from this we've seen how
customers use kubernetes well and maybe
how they use it poorly and issues that
you want to avoid from that we've taken
these battle tested and hardened
practices and baked it into the natural
config for autopilot additionally
similar to Cloud run but not quite the
same we're looking at how do we make
sure you're only paying for the
resources you use we will actually
easily scale up pods as you need more
capacity such that autopilot aligns your
usage with your cost I think all this
comes together for those who may not
have as much skill or platform team
strength to really be able to use
kubernetes quickly having that level of
automation makes it easier to get going
secondly similar Fleet experiences we've
learned a lot on security with security
instances working within the open source
Community as well as the very large
investment GK has put into kubernetes
across the board and we've taken these
security defaults and made it part of
the hardened config we actually actively
share this with the wider gka Community
as well such that everyone using GK is a
hardened experience with autopilot we've
got it baked in good example of this is
actually locking down nodes we found
doing this uses a great deal of config
errors and it had surface area and
increases the security
now on day two we've taken a lot of the
work for that Automation and built it
right into autopilot what's really cool
is it's actually our sres behind the
scenes managing the entire autopilot
Fleet now our sres are very very vocal
very skilled if they're listening but
very vocal and that supports a lot of
really good changes into autopilot such
as a very scalable Fleet and it's always
up to date this is ensured the latest
and greatest improvements security
controls you name it are baked right in
autopilot and SRE is right behind the
scenes
now what we heard as we've deployed all
upon a lot of clients is that you still
want control even if the upgrades are
automated you want to be able to align
when they occur with the needs of the
business such that it doesn't disrupt
things and this is where we leverage
what's baked into gke to give you that
flexibility on it I think lastly it's
also learning of how do we optimize our
scaling and our Behavior based on your
workloads and learning from that it says
that we Auto scale ideally the way you
want it and not just how we see it
hand in hand with autopilot is anthos
this is an offering that as Jason
mentioned earlier makes it much easier
to actually build and manage a platform
one of the cool things about anthos is
allows you to modernize your apps and
your infra in place no matter where
you're deploying it be it on-prem with
VMS or bare metal or in other clouds or
just on gcp anthos really has that
common experience across the board now
one really cool thing and something
that's grown a lot in demand is beyond a
scale multi-cluster applications one of
the neat things is Jason spoke about a
cloud Run is it makes that cluster
concept just go away and really
simplifies things so highly recommend
checking it out if you don't want to
deal with clusters at all but if you do
have a multi-cluster application or
you're dealing with a fleet of
kubernetes offerings anthos can make
this much simpler now a little bit in
contrast to autopilot it where we've got
a hardened very prescriptive way of
running kubernetes and those through a
variety of tools that are part of the
bundle gives you control and allows you
to deploy governance and security the
way you want either with anthos config
management or service mesh you can
figure exactly how you want it to your
particular line of business or your
entire company
one thing that we've actually seen is
that people will move between Cloud run
and gke so we've got a really cool demo
that actually shows us in action so you
can see how easy it is moved from cloud
run to gke
thank you drew let's continue the story
of my business app I'm handing over the
maintenance of my app to another team
they used Gigi autopilot for everything
and they want to know how hard it is to
move my app from cloud run to gke
let's go through the same installation
process again but on gke
I'll select the same container image I
used last time let's click select
let's use the latest version again and
click select again
I like how environment variables are
front and center in this form this time
I won't forget to fill those in I'm
setting the same memory instance IB
address here and I'm also setting the
same cloud storage bucket
I'll fill in a name for my workload and
click deploy
Tiki is now creating a new deployment on
the existing cluster
and the deployment is ready while
autopilot is still finishing up I'll go
ahead and click expose to create a
public endpoint
my container runs on port 8080 so I'll
fill it in and click expose
gkey is now creating a load balancer
with an external IP address for me
and it's done let's navigate to the new
service
alright great news the connection to the
memory store instance works out of the
box that's because the gke cluster is
already connected to the same VPC
Network
the connection to cloud storage fills
with an IAM error
I'll use workload identity to reuse the
Google cloud service account I've
previously set up for my cloud run
deployment
that means I don't have to configure the
IAM policy bindings again
I need to do four things to configure
workload identity
first I need to create a kubernetes
service account
second I'll link the two service
accounts together by adding an
annotation
third I need to Grant permissions to
allow the kubernetes service account to
act as the Google cloud service account
and finally I can redeploy my app and
set it to use the newly created
kubernetes service account that's it
let's get started I'll use cloud shell
Now to create a kubernetes service
account called app
I'll annotate the service account to
link it to the Google cloud service
account I've previously set up for my
cloud run service
now comes the granting permissions part
I need to allow the kubernetes service
account to use the Google cloud service
account and I do that using an IAM
policy binding
foreign
ly I can configure my app deployment to
use the kubernetes service account
I'll hit save and wait for gke to
redeploy my app
my app now runs on gke and on cloud run
you can see them side by side here both
apps are connected to the same memory
store instance
and both apps use the same Google cloud
service account
I'll tell the team that it wasn't hard
at all to move the app
I'm gonna hand it back to Drew now
thanks for the awesome demo that was
actually super cool one thing we've seen
really change within the past year is
the fact that more and more customers
aren't just running gke or aren't just
running Cloud run they're running both
and this is for a variety of reasons but
this is actually a very common pattern
across Google Cloud users a couple main
things that really show why this is
occurring number one is developer choice
you want and your developers want to be
able to use the right infra and the
right platform based on their particular
need of the time so at some points they
may want to get developing very very
quickly or they don't want to deal with
the burden of clusters and there's great
reasons like Jason spoke about to use
cloudron other teams may actually say
hey look I want to leverage kubernetes
and the ecosystem randomly use that and
as teams change as organizations changed
they may flow back and forth you want to
make sure you're not locked into one
platform I think this is pretty
fundamental to what we do and developers
are really enjoying it secondly is it's
a common set of tools for both this is
the cool bit about containers and also
the work we've done both on gka and
Cloud run such that you can use a common
set of development and deployment tools
for both systems as well as third-party
ecosystem it's not just the Google side
of this you really will have unhappy
developers if you're forcing to use
different tools for on-prem versus in
the cloud or between different systems
and I think this is where Cloud run
really excels with that level of
integration the fact we can then use the
advancements they've made with GK as
well
the last thing and this is probably one
of the best bits of Google cloud is
we're not looking to lock you in we
really want to make sure if you've got
the choice to be able to run where and
how you want and the ability to move we
saw the great demo and thanks for that
where you can actually move from cloud
run to gke but we're seeing customers
move the other way too and back and
forth hopefully not too often because
that's not productive for developers
either but there are definite reasons
based on skill availability especially
with kubernetes or on platform skill
availability where Cloud run is a great
use case for container development as
your team moves and communities you may
move and move back and we are doing a
lot of work to make it much easier to
move between the two and you'll see some
cool new announcements in the coming
year of how you can leverage both of
them the exact same time for common
workloads so you get the best of both
worlds now Jason and I wanted to ask you
to check out a couple of new sessions
Cloud runs got a really cool Banner URL
which I was quite jealous about and I'll
have to figure out an equivalent for gke
but if you want to learn more about
Cloud run and actually kick the tires
and try it out there's lots of great
demos information at Cloud dot run
additionally we've got a great session
BLD 107 they teach you many features you
can use to build modern apps much easier
with Cloud run on the flip side you've
got a less cool URL that I've got an
offer so it sort of balances out between
Jason and I at google.gle GK Dash offer
which gives you a great offer around
autopilot we have a really cool session
in partnership with pgs one of our
customers on how to run batch in HPC
workloads well within gke and a lot of
the lessons learned
so with that on behalf of Jason and I I
wanted to thank all of you for listening
in today highly encourage you to reach
out anytime if you got feedback on
either products and please enjoy the
rest of cloud next thank you
[Music]